pas facile de savoir qui en veut aux
lampadaires devait ce mot dans le
village
personne n'a rien vu rien entendu
absolument c'est pas ça séchait mystère
et boule de gomme voit un mystère pour
les habitants de cette rue un peu à
l'écart du village ce sont leurs
lampadaires à led qui sont visés par ces
vols de fusible située à 8 mètres de
haut après chaque dégradation le
quartier reste dans l'obscurité
ces lampadaires qui dérange apparemment
je trouve ça extrêmement bizarre qu'on
qu'on enlève la lumière ou alors que
c'est utile quoi quand même j'ai pas la
nuit se promener quand on est par
exemple une femme celle contre sur le
chien est finalement qu on a comme
surpris qu'on voit ce que vont aussi à
beaucoup d'habitants à cergy donc on se
demande je pense pas que ce soit une
personne âgée qui fasse quoi il faut
quand même être motivé pour lever un peu
au dessus des poteaux pour enlever des
lumières pendant que pour mon sport trop
grand chose dans la tête pour faire ce à
quoi parce que bon ça gêne tout le monde
en fait quatre fois que ces lampadaires
sont rénovés et de nouveau endommagé la
dernière réparation a tenu deux jours
seulement pour le maire ce sont des
frais conséquents pour sa petite commune
donc de la main de re de la nacelle donc
y ait de 413 euros pour une journée
montant total de la facture 500 euros
pour un lampadaire au delà du coup le
maire est surtout préoccupé par les
risques pris par le voleur
ce qui m'inquiète c'est le fait qu'il y
ait un accident un jour que quelqu'un
tombe depuis cette hauteur là
vous imaginez ce que ça pourrait ce qui
est des conséquences que cela peut avoir
pour la famille ou pour la commune donc
franchement non je souhaite vraiment
qu'il ya une discussion avec avec sept
personnes six et s'il y a un problème qu
en fait personne ne s'est encore
présenté pour se dénoncer
la mairie a déposé une plainte à la
gendarmerie et envisage de poser une
caméra de surveillance